steve is amazing and he really did
you know bring the whole thing to life
but i also felt
like a really a big responsibility for
telling the stories
it was most cases not lovers rock
actually but
tweedle's story and the other stories
were personal stories and and there was
a great obligation to really honor those
stories
first of all congratulations to you all
as small acts picked up five wins at
last night's bafta
tv craft awards um helen directly um for
production design and jacqueline for
costume design
um and also smallax is also nominated
for groundbreaking 15
uh nominations at this sunday's after
general awards
um what's it like being a part
of this winning production um especially
as you reflect how impactful small acts
has been overall and we'll go to
helen first wow
um what was it like it it was um
an amazing experience obviously
fantastic energy behind it with steve
he's such a he's such a
[Music]
you know incredibly intelligent man and
is a
great sort of sort of force
you know he he was um
[Music]
he just kind of really was really sort
of facilitated us
all i think you know in a way that was
very productive you know he gave us
he gave us a kind of strong idea of what
he was after
but then he let you kind of interpret
that and bring things to the table
yourself so
that's how it was really you know it was
just exciting it was exciting and it was
it was rewarding and um
yeah very gratifying to obviously had
all this kind of
attention as well as a result you know
it was a great it was great fun to do
i think there were two things first of
all was steve is amazing
and he really did you know bring the
whole thing to life
but i also felt like a really a big
responsibility for telling the stories
it was most cases not lovers rock
actually but
tweedle's story and the other stories
were personal stories and and there was
a great obligation to really honor those
stories
and like bring kind of the best your
best game to kind of
representing them on camera and and
steve was just
so so inspiring and so such a great
leader in in us all together bringing
these stories to the to the screen
that he is yeah he's amazing again yes
working with steve was the main
[Music]
thing for me i've never worked with
steve before
but it um and he was you know and i
took a while to get to know him
obviously i don't know how he works but
it was because it was a long process for
me i mean i'm sure it was for
the others too but i was doing this for
nearly a year and a half
and it was just an extraordinary year
you see it's like it sort of cut
coincided with some incredible like
world
events and i suppose i never realized
quite what it would
how meaningful the series would end up
being
at the beginning i just loved the
material and i sort of was really in
you know i love working with steve and
getting getting to you know sort of into
them into the stories and i just
it just sort of looks like a sort of
snowball really and
as last year sort of carry you know um
sort of finished it sort of became
bigger you know and
i think that was the thing it sort of
took me by surprise in a way
um i always loved the stories and that
was that went without saying but it was
just it had more significance as we went
on
as we worked on it more i think i mean
what the surprising impact
i want i don't know if i i was surprised
about the
the response to even my own emotional
response to the um
to the series and i think it's something
personal that what i haven't seen and
wanted to see for so long
being visualized and that took my breath
away
in my reaction to this wonderful series
but there was a lack of information
about the british black experience and
this is why it resonated so much
so for you guys to draw where did you
draw from
to start your process with this
narrative
and that hasn't been seen before i'll
start with um jacqueline
well i mean i had the two specific
episodes so one was lover's rock
and one was alex wheatle and the process
was slightly different because the
the the films are different you know one
is not somebody's personal story
but the story of one party on one night
in a specific place
so there was a sort there was a lot of
research went into that in a specific
way and
the alex wheatle story was based on his
life
really so the first thing or one of the
first things we did was when we went and
spoke to him
and talked to him about you know the
clothes he wore
the kind of environment he was in um the
life he had and he has an amazing memory
in fact his memory is so great that i
used some of the things he told me and
loves rock because it was just
he was he had the best memory of of
fashion in those specific years lovers
rock was interesting because
it's it's a it's a strange thing because
late 70s style has been reused again and
again and again
and so has lots of style related to
sound systems and everything it's quite
familiar
well relatively familiar and we kept
going we went through and through
just tons of photographic reference from
sound systems
and just general photography of that
date
and in there we found just a very few
pictures of women
in the specific style of dresses that we
ended up using
that that we just chose to be the way we
were going to represent
that party on that date and and it isn't
that that is the way that everybody
dresses that particular time but it is
one way
and it's a way that hasn't been
reinterpreted and reused and
regurgitated in fashion
quite as much as all the other looks so
it felt fresher and it felt new and it
was a
it was just a way for us to tell that
story
in a kind of slightly different way
and that was really photographic
reference there's just so much brilliant
photography from that period
thank you and um helen with the
production design it's actually i read
that you said you grew up during this
time
so yeah
that's about right i mean i did i did i
do remember those parties
um but i i was suggested um
something jacqueline's just said you
know that sort of seeing those
seeing those um people wearing those
clothes is so refreshing
to see that and quite captivating and
very very
um unusual to see that on screen and
that whole
film so unusual you know to have that
kind of um
time that devoted to it on on mainstream
television
you know just kind of never seen it
before at all and i think
i think that's what has kind of caught
people's imagination really
or you know caught the attention of
people it's just that it's very unusual
um sorry what was your question
and you know what i was trying to think
what did i ask um
is i think jumping off from what
jacqueline said about memory and
having alex wonderful memory to aid the
visual
yes you were drawing from experience of
being maybe having seen those parts what
else what else
pulls you in to get yeah yeah i mean i
did i did recognize aspects of what i
was you know what i was trying to
portray and there was a
load to learn because it was a lot i
didn't know at all
and you know for me it was the
excitement was working with steve
mcqueen and the stories and
you know this kind of opportunity to
design
for those periods as well um the
research side is is everything you know
there's but there is
like jacqueline says a lot a lot of
research to to be
found archives talking to people
photographs
videos you know all there's lots
um and in the end you have to kind of
filter it really and draw from it the
the elements that
interest you or that you think speak to
the stories we're trying to tell
and sort of um yeah gel gel them
together somehow
so it's a sort of hybrid really what you
end up with is a hybrid of all the
things you've seen all the things you've
learned
all the things you remember some i
suppose love as rock i remember
more and also actually education was one
i felt
quite um connected to because i went to
school
about the time of the story you know i
was about the same age as that character
so i kind of knew what the school was
like so
so yeah it's kind of drawing on my own
memories as well
[Music]
[Music]
you